medical miracles crop genetics top 40  entertainment ultra tech provides all of  this and more and when it comes to  military applications we know success  but looking forward does not always  provide the solutions we need for  today's battlefields sometimes we need  to look back introducing the lift or  Advanced Combat infiltration unit  combining patented bio technology and  cutting-edge cybernetic augmentation one  of the past's deadliest weapons  all new days done  Agnes  a self-sufficient  colors and genetic options available  contact your local Ultratech  representative and order today financing  available Ultratech looking to the plan  to preserve the future bow before the  herald of Gargas